we have this article that Adam actually
brought up and it's gonna make everyone
angry because I'm assuming there's a big
large group of men in the in the in the
chat
well it certainly annoys me I mean I I
got well people context on note story so
here it says how do I raised a good son
in a world that lets men be so bad and
and then really goes I just found out my
baby as a boy what a nightmare
oh it's just like you kidding me dude is
this guy tom Wyman so it's it's you know
it's gonna be a future father and it's
like I I read this before you before we
even get into it like what what is your
take on this guy you know what a loser
well yeah I mean I I feel like you're
the reason why men get to be so bad
because you don't you don't know what
you're doing you probably had a dad that
didn't have any idea what he's doing
you know it's like self-loathing it's so
easy you just talked to them and you
told you you you are there for them I
mean Adam now I don't have a child yet I
you know I plan on having kids someday
soon maybe I don't know you know but you
know if if it is a boy or a girl it
doesn't matter I'm gonna treat them like
a human being and talk to them well this
this is this is this might be shocking
to you oh no what
boys mm-hmm are people exactly and and I
know that it's actually they're actually
humans yes and then amazing it is
amazing I think think about like have we
ever I'm I was gonna bring up China a
little bit and their one-child policy
stuff yeah but I think everyone gets it
what they did to the female babies we
don't we don't want to go down a path of
you know one is worse or better than the
other but we have such an insane world
of propaganda because these media
companies in my opinion are chasing
after a narrative this guy president
believe any of this he's probably
thinking what can I write to get a
million views this is the toilet licking
of love journalism that is so true that
is exactly what this is saying I'm gonna
have a boy it's a nightmare is this is
the equivalent of licking a toilet yeah
I think you're right this guy's just
slobberin and and you know what more
than once
this is what it's
it's like he looked at toilet twice you
want to read it yeah
so I skipped ahead a little bit it says
last week my partner I found out the
gender of our gestating child is going
to be assigned at birth and ever since
the ultrasound technician turned to us
and said I can tell you that this little
person is going to be a little male
person I have not been able to stop
thinking about that strip it's like
before Edie got pregnant I always
assumed that if I did have a child I'd
want a girl I've been told that boys
have a tendency to pee directly in your
face when you're changing their diapers
so it seemed like with a girl at least
you'd be starting out learning how to
change a baby on easy mode that's
offensive girls are easy mode what's
that supposed to mean so that's what
it's about girls are easy you're afraid
to get bigots right in the face that's
fake he's making that up
I know exactly if you're worried about
getting peed in the face just put
something over it while you're changing
the diaper got here nice garden every
single one of my brothers stood on the
counter when they were like 2 or 3 years
old he's hiring everywhere free-range
buy honestly all I'm getting is he's
afraid of kids it doesn't matter not now
he's lying
oh yes this is yes this is virtue signal
101 absolutely well well I think men are
bad it's like dude you're met you're
married right like or no your partner
I'm sorry oh this is just oh yeah he
says plus there's a broader range of
cute clothes in which it's generally
considered socially acceptable to just a
baby girl dress baby girls up whoa whoa
whoa socially acceptable the dress the
visor I thought a child could be any
gender yeah so right why can't you put
your boy in a dress yeah you see the
problem here
he's trying to navigate the unnavigable
there are no rules nothing makes sense
and so right now he's conflated he's
mixed two different two different
ideologies yes betim girls have cute
clothes sorry you failed now he's gonna
get attacked by the left and the right
yeah well see he goes on to like ya know
I really don't yeah what are you over it
I am Mon de Beauvoir like I don't even
want to know what these guys I like I
did read through this when I first
and it's it's annoying it's it stalking
him he's like what am I supposed to do
talk about emotions to him and it's like
what yes what what what what am I
supposed to do like you know teach him
how to roughhouse in person yeah it's
like he's complaining about having to be
a father basically yeah that's that's
what this all boils down to and it's
just it's just annoying like and then
what's worse is after he's complaining
about having a kid a boy the very last
sentence here let's read this right
because what he says but having a son
can also as roast-beef realizes I have
no idea that is seem like something of a
night out of a nightmare I don't know if
you'd notice but men in the society are
often really not very good people we've
had a really hard time deciding on a
name for a boy because for the most part
whenever we found when we actually like
we've realized it's also the name of
some notable a-hole oh not this name
that was the name of a teacher who was
really patronizing to me or oh no that
one that's the name that's the same name
as a close friends terrible ex-boyfriend
names tend to pick up pick up a history
and when it comes to men's name that
history is typically highly ignominy
ignominious okay let me tell you
something I have ex-girlfriends too they
have names yeah am I never gonna say
their name again look if this guy was
real if this is serious mm-hmm he's
mentally unwell yeah I don't want to
have to say a name of something like how
many Tom Dick and Harry's are there and
if and if it is real I feel bad for his
son yeah man dude can we because
somewhat like no matter what he's
thinking is gonna happen that's gonna be
dude his kids gonna grow up this article
what he wants the Internet is forever
assuming the world doesn't end yeah this
kid's gonna grow up and at some point
see this and breed this yep and be like
do you thought I was a nightmare like
what Thanks like wow this is what he
thought of me or thanks roast beef is
that his name roast beef I don't even
know look at this if you're not careful
masculinity can turn what could once
have been a perfectly viable human being
into a selfish violent repository of
infantile neediness and poorly repressed
emotions this is psychosis
this is psych psycho
dude you idea about toxic masculinity
this dude is a perfect exhibit of taco
this is toxic femininity yeah yeah it's
the opposite yeah you know what this
reminds me of he's he's saying like
parks in Parks and Rec there's there's I
haven't seen the show in a while in a
why this is popping in my head but
there's this gay couple or the guys gay
and the woman isn't but they're married
and they're like against every single
thing that has to do with sex in in the
government like they're trying to teach
old old people because there's like an
STD outbreak in in like the old
Pearson's home and they're like the the
Parks and Rec ladies like we got to
teach these people so they don't spread
it anymore so they're trying to do like
sex ed class for these guys and they
storm in and they're like no this is
terrible and blah blah blah blah and
it's like it's
they're so against all things normal
traditional and this feels like it was
not even written by a guy this is and I
feel like she was over his shoulder like
a dude and add this add this in there
too and make sure make sure this way all
right hold on do you know what I'm
talking about we got to read this we got
this toxic can seam over used as an
adjective with which to accompany
masculinity but this is perhaps just
because of how extremely appropriate it
is too often masculinity can present
itself as a short as as a sort of
seething poison a noxious stench which
insinuates itself everywhere a malignant
parasite that tries to make everything
beholdin to it even the express
intention by those who bear it to escape
the worst aspects of masculinity seems
all too often to repeat its acts
excesses every quote not all men man is
trying to seek an exemption for
themselves every self-described male
feminist is probably just trying to get
laid the nice guy will storm out of the
room and make you follow him if you fail
to acknowledge how nice he is being for
men failing to be good often seems like
the easiest choice at every step so
they're basically saying every single
guy I figured it out as bad all men are
bad enlighten me two things first thing
yes he's talking about himself he has
very much the male feminist yeah 100%
he's projecting he's projecting exact
who he is self-described male feminist
is probably just trying to get laid he
knows it because it's him and he's
worried his kid will just be him that's
what he's really saying today yep
and now here's the other thing why is
that so many feminists think all men are
bad because the men they surround
themselves with are bad bingo they are
dudes like this I'll tell you what Adam
you seem like a pretty good dude
no thanks you don't hang out with these
people no neither do i I don't and
that's the thing the guys who are
surrounding these women are the nice guy
male feminist just trying to get laid so
they're surrounded by these skeevy dudes
who are dishonest and then regular good
masculine stoic guys are like I don't
wanna have anything to do with your
creepy ideology yeah it's true it's like
if you want to go believe in like you
know babies have no gender or whatever I
don't care
I'm gonna be over there yeah or then
hold on behind the male feminist goes I
I believe babies have no gender now that
I agree with you will you sleep with me
anyway might have a crumb why don't you
start go ahead and read the next
paragraph oh oh go for it I told you get
worse is this a parody just are you sure
it's not like I said it's not all right
he says obviously there's a caveat here
because who knows maybe as soon as my
child is able to talk they'll tell us
we've had everything wrong and they're
actually a girl oh geez here we go that
would present its own set of parenting
challenges but assuming he he sticks
with a gender the ultrasound technician
told us he's going to be given how can I
stop my son from growing up to be a
total prick it's called being a dad yeah
exactly
Wow I think you know that I think you
called it up yeah definitely it's him he
said he's a whiny pathetic nice guy
who's trying to get laid yeah that's all
wrong insane what is the outline he's a
contributing writer at the outline he's
a philosopher
no he isn't he's a child he's not you
wanna be the last paragraph in other
words if I want to escape the nightmare
possibility of my son growing up to be
the wrong sort of man I'm going to need
both to it both encourage and allow him
to be his own person and so I suppose I
need to forget that the little sitting
up
I'm sorry little one about the little
one sitting on one knee with the same
faces me I need to let go or I need to
let my son grow a face of his own I love
you so much already we lad I can't wait
to find out who you are this is the most
psychotic
oh so this is actually a really old
article well it's a year old
this kid is alive now this couldn't
concentrate on it and I'm worried for
this kid oh so the Kids Alive now yes
he's out and about how much you want to
bet it's completely fake like he was he
was he's sitting in his room and here's
what happened his wife walked in and she
was like Tom we are gonna be short for
this month's mortgage payment anyone
what if I I'll write an article
complaining about our son being male
that should get a few million clicks
from from well feminine yeah like good
good yeah let's do that
no she was like I don't care what you
write yeah just write something that
makes money yeah and then so he writes
the first draft and he's like I think
I'm gonna publish this and she goes no
no no you need to say that you you don't
want to sign it all that all men are
parasites
that'll get clicks and he goes good idea
yeah it I hope you're right I don't how
did you find this front pocket oh it's a
pretty great source of different
articles and stuff they this is a cult
yeah this is like a weird dogmatic
religion that makes no sense
it is little culty if you came to me and
said all of group of people are bad I'd
be like I do not like that I do not want
to associate with that I'm sorry I'm
sorry no no no no hold on hold on nope
nope I'm wrong I got what that back no
I'm sorry oh yeah no no I actually I've
actually met some okay communist and I
mean that I really do I do not agree
with the idea that literally every
person is irredeemable or bad especially
based on their musical care immutable
characteristics look I've met communists
III tell the story often a guy he was
wearing a mask with a sickle and a
hammer and he was giving out literature
and I asked him how he felt about ante
foe violence and he said that's terrible
that's awful
and I was like really I was like I'm
surprised I thought you'd agree there's
like nah man he's like true freedom and
and and and like communism would be
everyone being equal and if you're equal
you can't attack somebody else yeah and
I was like my man
and so we talked about it and I said I
completely disagree with your view on
how a market could work I do not believe
it's possible coming but I but I
appreciate that you're heading out
literature having conversations with
people and denouncing violence that's
all I guess all I can really ask for
that's how that's that's a great thing
and we can you can talk about this stuff
so yeah I don't even have friends who
are like woke feminists as long as
you're an authoritarian who cries and
screech on the internet you can believe
dumb things yeah because they think I
believe dumb things but this article is
poison I'm worried for this kid I'm
worried for other other people who might
read this and think it's real I hope
remember we were talking about with
celebrities screeching and saying insane
crap because they read garbage like this
yeah and I think that's what people like
all of these celebrities jobs are is to
get clicks and get traffic they are
professional toilet bowl liqueurs yeah
boom we're gonna call it that well I
don't think this is a parody because
this is on Pocket and they don't they
don't put stuff on there that's right
that's real Twitter ask him a bunch of
questions sure you know what please do I
might I would love these people are fake
man this guy's a grifter what person is
gonna be like I can't believe I have a
son because men are evil it's like
that's fake dude I mean hey people
they're cultists thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you